an unassuming tavern the scene of
unimaginable terror abandoned belongings
outside speak to the chaos that unfold
within in the early hours of the morning
a group of gunmen opened fire here
randomly indiscriminately at least 15
are dead several more seriously injured
those who saw it left reeling some too
fearful to be identified
we were playing pool and drinking when
suddenly people barged in and started
shooting i survived because i hid under
the pool table so many other people got
shocked
i was at home when we heard gunshots go
off we've become so used to the sound of
gunshots in this area so i didn't go
outside to investigate i was later woken
up by my next door neighbor telling me
that people had been shot at the tavern
and it was really bad
as the community gathered to grieve grim
details emerged multiple shooters a rush
to escape the weapons rifles and nine
millimeter pistols
thank you thank you for your help but
police as yet have no clear theory as to
why and there's a sense people are angry
crime has defeated our systems we need
to just rise from the ashes and the only
way to rise is to come together with the
people of south africa to fight to climb
that anger is understandable here in the
township of soweto a place created under
apartheid still tormented by issues of
poverty crime and a feeling of being
left behind
south africa's murder rate is already
one of the steepest in the world experts
say the pandemic has made things worse
what i think we have seen more of
in recent times is a rise in organized
crime
and particularly crimes around or
involving
organized gangs criminal networks and
certainly
gangs that are working in extortion
rings that are really trying to extort
many small business owners
and others for protection fees
or security records and this has
definitely gotten worse in the last two
years with the covert pandemic that
really shut down
the sort of regular trade of of a lot of
criminal groups
even so a shooting on this scale is rare
and shocking this is a community that
may well dream of a future free from
sporadic violence but they also just
want answers helen ann smith sky news